So, to put this in perspective, we're very pleased with our year-over-year performance,...
...particularly in light of the weak economy.
And the economic situation continues to be tough as we all know.
We saw relative stability in our business in the second quarter.
It's too early for us to tell when the recovery will materialize.
I wish we could just prove it, you know.
We can do the analysis and figure it out.
But we don't know how to do that yet.
So, when the recovery does come and it always eventually comes,...
...we are very well-positioned for the future,...
...given our constant and continuing investment in innovation.
So with that, Patrick.
Thank you very much.
Go ahead.